e-body renew by madame and masseur
specializes in non-physical workouts
and luxury rocky caught up with the team
to see their location
at the sterling club
when you enter the beautiful and
prestigious sterling club you're greeted
by friendly service
and luxury whether you're enjoying the
salon
the spa the gym or
e-body renew the treatment is
a combination of a machine and a diet
and this is excellent in the time of
covet because we all feeling depressed
and down
what the treatment does it helps the
endorphins in the brain
and make you feel better and make you
relax you come to the salon twice a week
we take care of you we pamper you
we help you with your eating plan we
motivate you because
motivation is what we all need at the
moment
this is beautiful amy she needed to just
tone and firm and use a bit of cellulite
and get a bit of strength my experience
has been fantastic
i love coming here for my treatments and
i usually have a couple problem areas
like cellulite
my arms and my stomach so i come in and
do these treatments and i feel great not
only do i get a workout
and get my muscles tone but i'm getting
ready for my photo shoots for my
pageants
and afterwards the stamina that i have
after the treatments are incredible
she's getting strained from the
treatment she's getting sculpted from
the treatment
because remember it's not like a laser
that is just going to break down your
fatty tissue it's going to stream from
your muscle
and women aren't the only ones who
deserve this kind of
special treatment the treatment is
really incredible
it is open to everybody men women
overweight patients
non-overweight patients and children can
go on the treatments but what i really
specify and
work on is men that wants to lose that
little extra
executive gut you know you're in the gym
all day you work out you do everything
you can do but you can't get rid of it
my machines goes down and break down the
fatty tissue and do
muscle react so get rid of your gut
ben is a wonderful client of mine
international business executive from
australia so you hear all these accents
here
we helped him to get rid of that little
gut that he had
been amazing to go through those
treatments uh the last couple of months
and i think we're up to about 10
treatments now and i think i've lost
about
four inches off off the stomach in that
time and uh
about six pounds as well so you can go
to the gym all day you can go do cardio
all day
but unless you really know how to target
those muscles
and break down that fat that's gonna
stay there anybody renew doesn't just
give you give you weight loss or shape
your body
eat body when you create blood
circulation throughout your body and
will detox your body
i think it's done a lot for my
metabolism because i never really
noticed anything
changing hormonally or anything because
of the body for instance my lungs were
bad and they're fixed now because it
gets all the ox it's just
so good for everything
check out ebody renew at the sterling
club for more information you can call
that number seven zero two four four
four
zero two two nine or go to their website
at ebodyrenew.com
they have a really good special right
now you can get your first 179 dollar
value treatment for just
sixty nine dollars jason